[Music]
my name is lawrence jones and i've been
at fox for three years when someone is
hearing about fox news i think the
elephant in the room is they don't
expect someone that looks like me we
can't have anarchy so i get here and i'm
here just as a contributor i'm this
young man and then sean hannity sees me
on tv he says i want to meet with you i
love my job good evening so sean hannity
says i want you to be my man on the
street man who doesn't know sean hannity
this is the guy that's been at fox the
longest he is the star lawrence jones lj
i don't think this is gonna be a good
idea he goes why not
i said well i'm a libertarian you're a
strong republican conservative man and
sometimes i disagree with the party he
goes well that won't be a problem when
we disagree
he'll just be you he said just be lj
i could just be me